hey this is presh talwalkar
mathematical induction is a powerful
proof technique involving two steps
step one prove a statement is true for
the base case usually n equals zero or n
equals one
step two prove that
if the statement holds for some natural
number n
then the statement also holds for n plus
one
this creates a logical domino which then
proves that the statement holds for all
natural numbers
let's do an example to prove that the
sum of the first n odd numbers is equal
to n squared
we start with the base case of the first
odd number
it is true that one is equal to one
squared
we now assume the formula is true for n
and then we want to show that it is also
true for n plus one the next odd number
which will be two larger
which will then be two n plus one
how can we prove this formula will also
have the same form
we start out with the sum of the first n
odd numbers and we know that is equal to
n squared by the inductive hypothesis
we have the sum of the first n plus one
odd numbers is therefore equal to n
squared plus two n plus one
we can now factor n squared plus two n
plus one
to get
n plus one the quantity squared
and this shows the formula also holds
for the next odd number
therefore we have proven the statement
by induction
we'll now get to the thing i want to
show you in this video which is we will
prove that in every group size n
everyone has the same age
this will be a false proof but we're
going to proceed by induction and the
challenge for you is to figure out where
the mistake in this proof
is
step one
in a group of size n equals one there is
only one person
everyone in this group trivially has the
same age
therefore we have checked the base case
of n equals one
now we will show whenever the statement
is true for a group of size n it will
also be true for a group of size n plus
one
consider a group with n plus one people
that we will number from one to n plus
one
if we remove person n plus one from the
group then the remaining set of people
from 1 to n is a group of n people
by the induction hypothesis
everyone in this group has the same age
similarly
if we remove person 1 then the remaining
set of people from two to n plus one is
also a group of n people
once again by the induction hypothesis
everyone in this group has the same age
by steps four and five
persons n and n plus one have the same
age as everyone else in the group
numbered from one to n minus one
and therefore they have the same age as
each other
this means everyone in the group has the
same age
by induction we have proved everyone has
the same age for groups of any size
therefore everyone in the world has the
same age
naturally this is an absurd conclusion
so the question is
which step has the mistake
can you figure it out
give it a moment of thought before
watching the rest of the video
so each step in this proof is valid
except for step six
it is not true that persons n and n plus
one will have the same age even though
they could have the same age as everyone
else in the group
why is that
the statement is not always true with
the group of just two people
consider a group with one and two
if we remove person one from the group
then everyone remaining which is just
person two
that person does have the same age and
if you remove person two then everyone
remaining which is just one
also has the same age
however
just because everyone else remaining has
the same age
does not mean that one and two will have
the same age as each other
person one may have the age of one and
person two may have the age of two
so this is the flaw in this proof that
it will not work when n equals two and
therefore the induction domino effect
doesn't happen we can't say it's
therefore then true for three and four
and so on so clearly not everyone in the
world has the same age
induction is a powerful proof technique
but each step has to be valid or you may
end up with an absurd conclusion
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions that you can
follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description